[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique sur la chaîne
parlementaire après la sécurité et la
santé l'économie ce soir focus sur
l'économie française et la santé de nos
entreprises autre thème bien sûr qui
structure le débat de la campagne
présidentielle comment vont-elles les
entreprises résistent est la langue de
choc de la guerre en ukraine c'est le
patron des patrons notre invité ce soir
bonsoir geoffrey robertson
vous êtes à la tête du medef l'économie
française affronte ce qu'elle déteste le
plus un niveau d'incertitude maximum et
la guerre un direct indirect que nous
menons à la russie à un prix élevé pour
nous pour les entreprises le plomb
résilience est il bien calibré
croissance augmentation des salaires
comptes publics quel est votre
diagnostic et quelle est votre vision de
l'avenir sur toutes vos questions sur
toutes ces questions ce sombre et gilles
bouchez tomes traduits qui viendront
vous interrogez il très rare évoquera la
place de l'économie dans la campagne
vincent roux nous appellera du figra
live dans une quinzaine de minutes pour
vous poser une question d'actualité mais
d'abord on va s'arrêter ensemble sur les
entreprises est d'abord les entreprises
en russie geoffroy roux de bézieux pour
ma part j'ai découvert qu effectivement
la place la france avait une place
prépondérante dans l'économie russe soit
160 mille salariés au total c'est
beaucoup
de très nombreuses entreprises et des
intérêts financiers aussi important
depuis le début de cette guerre il y à
28 29 jours pardon je me trompe
peut-être d'une unité est ce que vous
leur dit faites vos valises ou est ce
que vous leur dites rester et fait le
gros dos malheureusement d'abord c'est
pas moi de leur dire c'est chaque
entreprise qui décide mais d'abord c'est
le gouvernement et les sanctions qu'on
doit suivre et en suisse et sociaux et
je jure quand même mettre les choses
dans l'ordre c'est à dire que l'économie
passe après et les risques économiques
et les impacts technip à ça près c'est à
dire la défense de nos valeurs et donc
depuis le début nous les entreprises on
suit
au mot près la minute près les décisions
du gouvernement les gouvernements
français comme le demande pas aux envies
de française de partir à 10 fait pour le
mieux et c'est compliqué il ya des
emprises ce françaises qui ont décidé
d'arrêter de suspendre leurs activités
mais quand on a beaucoup d'employés sur
place les expatriés sont rentrés partir
ça veut dire quoi concrètement parce que
si je prends des magasins ou des banques
va partir ça veut dire que les banques
vont continuer simplement elles vont
être nationalisée par le gouvernement
russe et elles vont continuer sous
direction russe donc c'est pas un savait
pas renoncé à dire que les entreprises
qui restent elles sont toutes menacées
de nationalisation quel que soit le
secteur bien sûr poutine a passé une loi
la loi passe au parlement assez
facilement
général qui appartement ou une emprise à
plus de 25% de capital étranger et qu
elle décide de prendre une action qu'ils
considéraient comme hostile par le
gouvernement russe elle peut être
nationalisées c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs pour quelques entreprises
américaines qui sont partis mais qu'ils
avaient des petits effectifs et donc la
réalité c'est que en fait le choix n'est
pas binaire et elles font comme elles
peuvent via le sujet des salariés locaux
qu'il faut continuer à payer en fait en
réalité et à le sujet aussi de la
population russe un qui n'a pas choisi
cette guerre alors on se passait le
soutien soutient pas la guerre mais
quand on vend des produits alimentaires
de première nécessité fermé et encore
une fois la possibilité de fermer n'est
pas vraiment dans les mains des
décisionnaires de paris c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre oui mais c'est
intéressant parce que nous on a
l'impression en regardant
un peu loin qu'il ya des stratégies
différentes dès le début de la guerre on
a entendu des marques et pas des moins
des marques très connues comme ikea
comme starbucks et qui a suédois
starbucks américain dire nous on part et
puis on a vu les grandes entreprises de
luxe française aussi partir ok les
autres dont
les autres danone total sa elle reste
donc on s'est dit bon il y en a c'est
business as usual mais je comprends
qu'on croit que c'est pas pardon c'est
une vue un peu lointaine des sujets
je prends l'exemple de mcdonald's
mcdonald's comment s'est mis en avant
dix on quitte la russie mais c'est pas
vrai les franchisés magal qui oppresse
l'essentiel des restaurants mcdonald's
sont toujours ouverts et vendre des
produits mcdonald's en russie entre
et bien sûr le mémoire je suit le
chiffre quand il ya 800 mcdo il y en a
je crois moins 200 qui ont fermé et
encore je passe l'essentiel c'était des
franchises mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que maintenant qu'il ya plus
d'expatriés le pouvoir d'un actionnaire
depuis paris de décider même quand il
est à 100% est pas automatique alors je
parle pas des joint-ventures enfin
dépendons des ouïes des joint-ventures
ya un actionnaire russe est un
actionnaire européen enfin en tout cas
nombreux le pouvoir est pas évident la
société générale et co actionnaire d'une
banque elle peut pas décider tout seul
deux entre guillemets partie on peut
décider de fermer mais non mais des fois
ferme et paie ses employés bien sûr mais
là je dis pas que c'est facile mais
icade va être nationalisée les magasins
vont rouvrir
jeudi sur la loi elle est à ladoux mal
alors à l'heure où on parle enfin la
chambre russe mais c'est compliqué comme
sujet mais encore une fois toutes les
entreprises allant françaises et
européennes sont toutes dans ce lit dès
mai les seuils de combiner j'ai à dire
le mot dire le dilemme de morale parce
que personne ne veut soutenir l'invasion
de l'ukraine et la réalité pragmatique
plus la guerre dure plus les entreprises
vont se retirer il ya de la majorité un
presse française ont arrêté d'exporter
même celles qui sont pas sous sanction
parce que même les produits qui sont pas
sous sanction une grande partie a
suspendu ses investissements certaines
ont fermé temporairement quand elles ont
pu tout au début parce qu'elle avait
encore le contrôle quand une fois un
quand il ya des expatriés sur place qui
dont la loyauté vis-à-vis du siège est
forcément plus forte que celle de saraya
us c'est plus facile donc c'est pas une
solution c'est pas une situation comment
dire
binaire simple en disant il ya qu'à
partir j'appuie sur le bouton je perds
c'est fini ça comme ça reste une
curiosité quand une entreprise est
nationalisée donc elle vend des produits
qui sont fabriqués sur place donc vous
dites
nationalisée peut-être les franchise
mcdonald's peut-être aussi donc ça sera
du russe 100% fabrication figurant je
n'ai pas d'exemple en tête mais il ya
sûrement des entreprises qui sont encore
ouvertes sur place qui importe des
produits d'autres pays la distribution
présente via le cadeau chantons
parlement ou au chant à des fournisseurs
agroalimentaires russe et donc vend des
produits russes en russie
donc bon si il arrive à fermer leurs
magasins ils seront réouverts dans la
foulée par le pouvoir russe donc c'est
ça qui est très compliqué c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'on pense comme on
allume et qu'on ferme encore des
questions alors loris de rester vous
l'avez dit c'est la nationalisation il
ya un risque aussi ce qu'on appelle un
risque réputationnel on est bien sûr
rester dans un pays qui sous le propre
avec un poutine qui décide tout seul je
vous fais pas le tableau vous avez
compris il ya des enjeux de
l'exploitation des deux parties bien sûr
in d un des éléments de décision il ya
d'abord le jas dire l'aspect moral mais
il ya aussi l'aspect business pour le
reste des marchés ce qui est compliqué
c'est que on ne demande pas aux
entreprises françaises européennes de
partir partout où les gens rentrent en
guerre au moyen-orient il ya eu des
invasions ou yémen l'arabie saoudite qui
a envoyé des troupes pour autant
le sujet s'est pas posé de la même
manière mais évidemment la liste est
géographique et bien sûr je comprends
tout ça fait que petit à petit je pense
que malheureusement mais y aura pas
d'autre choix les entreprises
européennes vont petit à petit suspendre
leurs activités dans la mesure où elles
le peuvent parce que la guerre dure et
parce que la situation est intolérable
même total cg100 ces cas particuliers de
total bruno le maire avec des autos
début ça avait été un problème de
principe à rester
il n'a pas réitéré au contraire il a vu
je crois patrick
total explique
je crois enfin d'adn d'une société dans
lequel l'actionnaire russe à 80% au bout
d actionner russe donc partir ça veut
dire quoi ça pas dire fermer l'activité
puisque avec l'intention du capital vous
avez aucun pouvoir de fermer quoi que ce
soit ces données les 20% à l'actionnaire
russe voyez je sais dire je cède pour un
euro ou 0,20 à double donc qu'est ce que
ça change à la situation de la guerre
rien que ce que ça change à la solution
de la société rien simplement si un jour
poutine accepte de revenir à la table de
négociation ce qu'on peut espérer
n'en prend pas le chemin aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on arrêtera complètement de
faire du commerce a réussi une fois
qu'ils ont arrêtés qu'ils ont retiré
leurs troupes probablement pas encore
que j'en sais rien et donc on a une vue
un peu sais pas comment dire un peu
théorique de tout ça dans la réalité
c'est que des cas pratiques et ses des
dilemmes très compliqué qui à chaque
fois se pose différemment en fonction de
la nature de l'activité sur place et du
type d'activité c'est un peu théorique
enfin c'est impec un agresse un autre et
bien sûr en europe pour
pas existé
on n'avait encore jamais vu et on
chausse la question à la fois toutes les
questions vous assurer que tous les
patrons pays qui ont une activité tous
les patrons d'entreprise qui ont une
activité bas se pose la question tous
les soirs tous les matins disant
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour aider les
ukrainiens que ce que j'en viens pour
aider mais c'est la russe que ce que je
peux faire pour pas cautionner cette
agression encore une question avant de
rejoindre
vincent roux mais elle est importante
il ya aussi des entreprises françaises
en ukraine là où évidemment les villes
et le peuple et bombardier ont les mêmes
leroy leroy merlin alors qui appartient
à méliès la famille mulliez s il ya une
grande un grand dépôt au nord-ouest sens
commercial dans un centre commercial au
nord-ouest de kiev qui a été bombardé
aujourd'hui vous êtes au courant il ya
au moins huit morts dernier bilan que
j'ai vu passer les salariés de cette
branche ukrainienne de leroy berlin ont
lancé une pétition pour que cesse
l'activité de leroy merlin en ukraine
mais c'est un peu on comprend tout à
fait je sais pas quelle est la position
j'ai pas je suis papa toute la journée à
toutes les entreprises et la seule chose
que peut faire leroy merlin c'est dire
je laisse l'entreprise aux russes elle
peut pas obliger
aux russes sur place ou à la direction
russe ce qu'il faudrait en étant le
kremlin oui mais ce que demandent les on
peut il craignent un c'est de fermer un
magasin oui et donc on retombe sur la
même question c'est comment on fait
concrètement quand on est basé à paris
depuis l occurrence dans le nord je
crois que ce sont près de lille pour
obliger les directeurs de magasin et les
patrons russes de l'enseignent de fermer
et si jamais ils fermaient
nationalisations dans la foulée
réouverture par les russes mais c'est
peut-être ça qui va se passer je sais
pas quelle décision ils vont prendre on
peut décider de
l'intérieur par exemple on re lisez
cette mort mais
et après aller plaider devant un
tribunal moscovite avec un avocat russe
il n'y a plus de droit il ya plus de
droits mais d'ailleurs pendant de lire
comme ça mais quand vous nationalisez
comme ça d'une loi sans aucune raison y
a plus d'état de droit en russie c'est
tout le problème est déjà pas beaucoup
de droit mais je vais rarement un coût
mais il n'y en a plus
est ce que vous êtes vous alors c'est
peut-être un titre personnel vous pouvez
vous exprimer mais au titre de la
direction du medef ce que vous seriez
pour une intervention
d'un petit peu plus conséquente est ce
que vous pensez qu'il était un logo à
tort de refuser
d'instaurer une
d'interdiction aérienne je vais vous
faire deux réponses la première c'est
que la vraie parce que ça répond la
questure présent la vraie sanction
économique c'est pas de fermer des
magasins ou des agences bancaires qui
seront réouvertes dans la foulée cdh a
racheté du bar était d'acheter du
pétrole et du gaz russe tous les jours
l'europe paye 400 millions d'euros 400
millions d'euros à la russie et à gaza
pour le gaz et proment 200 pour le pour
le pétrole est sain si on arrivait
collectivement à s'en passer
évidemment ça mettrait la russie
économiquement à genoux c'est pas parce
qu'on va lancer merlin alors il ya de
réponse malheureusement la france est
prête à le faire nous on n'achète que 16
millions par jour c'est 3% des achards
j'ai
aimé mais aussi sous tout le paradoxe
tous les pays de l'ex bloc soviétique la
pologne la tchéquie les pays baltes et
quant à votre et sont sur votre question
pardon sur la no fly zone non je ne
crois pas parce qu'on rentrerait à ce
moment là dans une escalade qui peut
nous mener vraiment à quelque chose de
très grave votre conviction ma
conviction c'est qu'il faut arriver à se
restreindre collectivement du gaz russe
sacré à une très forte récession on
aurait en plusieurs mois
ne croyez pas ça la main j'étais le
patron du bd y donc le medef allemand
tout à l'heure visioconférence
il nous dit trois en trois ans ils sont
en train de relancer leur chantera de
charbon tous les trois ans pour se
passer à 100 % du gaz russe et là
honnêtement si on se dit les choses
monsieur schröder d'abord et madame
merkel après sont collectivement très
coupable parce qu'ils ont amplifié la
dépendance de l'industrie allemande au
gaz russe à la fois en faisant le
premier pipeline le north stream 1 puis
le nord stream 2 qui heureusement ne
rentrera pas
en marche puis la fermeture du nucléaire
et donc on est dans une situation qui
est absurde où en fait on prend des
sanctions économiques qui certes sont
absolument nécessaires parce que
moralement il faut les prendre mais
qu'il n'affaiblisse pas réellement la
russie on va poursuivre ce débat dans
quelques instants mais on va passer
d'abord par le figaro live avec vincent
roux bon soir vincent bonsoir elisabeth
bonsoir geoffroy roux de bézieux soit là
vincent roux est là vincent
basso froid ou désuète à votre question
avec la question j'espère bien il est
question concernent sept cette attaque
qui a eu lieu en france en bretagne par
une cinquantaine de manifestants d'une
cargaison comportant 1500 tonnes de blé
ces deux millions d'euros de préjudice
geoffroy roux de bézieux est ce que vous
diriez comme julien dray l'ancien député
ps que c'est le gauchisme bobo dans
toute sa stupidité c'est criminel de
détruire des milliers de tonnes de blé
en temps de crise
déjà en temps normal c'est absurde ces
actes audiences n'ont pas de nom pas de
raison d'être mais voilà en plus comme
ils se sont incomplets tromper de
cargaison est trompé de destinataire ça
fait quand même beaucoup et je sais ma
ça je sais pas s'il assume enfin
j'espère
j'espère qu'ils seront condamnés fameux
poursuivi puis puis de condamner et
comme vous le savez mille cinq cent
mille 500 tonnes de blé on va en avoir
besoin parce qu'on parle beaucoup du gaz
mais un des problèmes créés par la crise
russe c'est le blé ukrainien qui
nourrissent de vin qui ne passent plus
les ports de la mer noire et qui ont
fait monter multiplié par trois ou
quatre jeux c'est plus le le coût de la
tonne de blé dont on n'a pas encore vu
les conséquences dans nos linéaires
dans nos baguettes en quelque sorte donc
oui c'est du jeu même pas si c'est du bo
bo je crois que c'est de la bêtise de
combiner avec de la violence de la
stupidité j'espère qu'on sévira parce
que c'est aussi grave que d'autres actes
de violence et ça mérite d'être condamné
c'est votre réponse vincent merci je
veux ma réponse merci merci beaucoup à
vous la semaine prochain représente
brigitte busch est en train de mouiller
on commence avec vous tam sur les
indicateurs de l'économie bonsoir
geoffroy roux de bézieux bruno le maire
pense que l'économie française est
suffisamment solide pour résister à la
guerre en ukraine est ce que vous êtes
de son avis je vais vous dire j'ai fait
une réponse qui est peut-être pas une
bonne réponse je sais pas honnêtement de
l'ampleur de la crise honnêtement je
disais avant l'émission et les lettres
marty que j'étais en ukraine mois de
juillet avec une régulation de patron
j'avais pas du tout eu ce sentiment
qu'ils avaient tous d'être menacée par
la russie et donc je serai très peu dans
mes prévisions plus la guerre dure
plus les conséquences sur l'économie
européenne et mondiale mais beaucoup
européenne quand même un les états unis
sont quand même beaucoup plus posée faut
répondre aujourd'hui les calculs qu'on a
faits donnent à peu près ce que disait
bruno le maire autour de 1% d'impact sur
le piolet mais je vois le prix du blé je
vois le prix de l'acier j'ai vu que ce
matin même l'australie va arrêter
l'exportation de bauxite vers la russie
la bauxite ça permet de faire de
l'aluminium l'aluminé s'appelle fait de
l'aluminium mais donc ça veut dire que
ça ait duré que 1 % si l'on peut dire ça
peut être plus il ya d'autres facteurs
qui sont aggravant quand même le retour
de l'épidémie des cabines de kovy en
asie en corée en particulier donc je
bon on a appris les uns les autres est
relativement prudents dans nos mais
voyez j'ai pas du tout de même sentiment
qu'avec le copil jeu pas si vous
souvenez mois de mai 2020 j'avais pris
un peu tout le monde par surprise en
étant le pire est pas certain il y aura
pas le million de chômeurs à l'époque
c'était ce qui était pris par le
gouvernement n'ont pas mûres des
faillites j'avais eu quelques
quelques ricanements des uns des autres
bons c'est effectivement s'est passé
parce que j'étais vraiment persuadé que
le vaccin on est on est face à quelque
chose de certes surprenant mais
rationnel l'un pardon de le dire mais on
est face à city national tchadien une
irrationalité absolue on ne sait pas ce
que veut poutine on ne sait pas à quel
moment il va s'arrêter on sait pas ce
qu'il est prêt à négocier
quand vous connaissez l'histoire
de l'ukraine qui est un pays très récent
qui à 30 ans arrêtés d'ailleurs c'est le
discours qu'il a tenu si peu souvenirs
entrée en guerre il peut effectivement
raconter une histoire de dire tout ça
c'est la russie éternelle historiquement
est en partie vrai et donc je ne
m'arrête que quand j'aurai récupéré la
fille or c'est un pays 600 mille mètres
carrés six cent mille kilomètres carrés
pardon où il ya le guérilla a duré très
longtemps après 45 jusqu'en 54 il y
avait une guérilla anti communiste ça
peut durer très longtemps s'abattre
inquiète c'est que ça dure on sait que
ça dure ça met à table et je ne veux pas
si vous voulez mon inquiétude et les
d'abord pour les pour les ukrainiens
enfin pour les populations mais mais
forcément c'est à notre porte et sera
des conséquences sont donc je sais pas
répondre à votre caisse juste une autre
question sur un autre gros indicateur
très important actuellement c'est
l'inflation on va vers 4% d'inflation
nous dit on est ce qu'on est parti selon
vous pour que ça dure pour que ce soit
une spirale inflationniste là aussi non
là aussi non non là je vais vous
répondre je ne veux pas passer pour
jédir un mauvais prêts fin d'un prince
on dirait un devin mais mois d'octobre
pareil monsieur villeroy de galhau dit
non il y aura un petit pic d'inflation
majuli c'est là pour durer et
effectivement je pense que c'est là pour
durer en alimentaire on n'a pas vu
le début de l'inflation est la
conséquence de l'augmentation des
matières premières dans les prix que
vous payez gérer 1 4% et peut-être même
plus parce que vous savez l'inflation
mais je vois comment ça se passe dans
les entreprises mettaient du temps à
passer les hausses de prix sauf si vous
êtes en direct
avec les consommateurs quand l'acier
augmente la cie augmenté de 20% quand la
cie augmente immédiatement le prix des
voitures n'augmente pas de 20% le prix
des chantiers qui prennent de l'acier et
enfin débridée donc il faut du temps
l'exécration long way donc je pense
qu'on n'est pas d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses on est à quatre en france on
est plutôt à 5 en europe et on nettoie
sa dette aux états unis donc je pense
qu'on est effectivement parti dans un
cycle qui est difficile à imaginer ce
qu'on appelle la boucle inflation
salaire pour un petit moment
oui des conséquences sur les entreprises
est ce que vous envisagez des faillites
des licenciements à cause de cette
guerre en ukraine alors j'ai peut-être
vous choquer en dise ça l'inflation dans
l'absolu on a vécu des années où il y
avait de l'inflation ce qui est terrible
et très dangereux c'est l'hyper
inflation c'était le moment où on
commence à courir derrière les housses
de serre pour compenser les hausses de
prix etc on n'en est pas là aujourd'hui
objectivement la situation prises
françaises
elle est plutôt bonne elle était très
bonne avant les événements fin la gare
nuque raide il faut pas appeler ça les
événements l'agression de la russie en
ukraine tout c'est comme ça la vérité
donc c'est encore une fois ça dépend de
la durée et des conséquences il ya des
fondamentaux qui sont seuls et où la
politique de l'offre qui a été menée
depuis 2016 pas depuis 2010 est ou
devient 2014 le cice vous souvenez
peut-être que mon prédécesseur avait
promis un million d'emplois alors ils
sont là les millions d'emplois sont même
plus que leur simplement comme toujours
en économie quand on prend une mesure
c'est en général pas le glas et michael
a pris qui en bénéficient parce que ça
met du temps je vous ai entendu juste
revenir sur l'économie parce que j'avais
entendu parler de croissance et
d'inflation est ce qu'on peut aller vers
une stagflation ce qui serait assez
grave non c'est quand j'aurai pas
répondre répondre je ne sais pas à
chaque fois mais mais je viens scénario
qui est pas exclu totalement qu'a connu
le japon quelques nus fincke ont connu
un certain nombre de deux je sais pas
vous répondre finalement la clé dans
tout ça c'est la confiance et qu'il
marche et c'est l'économie de la
confiance parce que vous avez confiance
dans l'avenir que en tant que chef
d'entreprise vous investissez vous en
boucher ou en tant que consommateur vous
achetez donc temps que ces événements où
cette guerre en ukraine on sait pas où
ça va aller il ya une sorte de
glaciation qui peut effectivement durer
longtemps est ce que vous craignez sinon
des pénuries et dans quels domaines non
là il faut pas c'est à dire il faut pas
alerter on trouvera des sources
d'approvisionnement
ce que les pénuries elles vont se
concentrer sur des trucs très très
particulier le titane le palladium et
celui des sols
l'huile d'olive donc je jure comme du
tournesol mais non mais au delà de la
boutade non on va pas manquer de vivres
dans les supermarchés semi conducteurs
non plus oui mais c'était c'est comment
dire c'est ponctuel c'est parce qu'elle
est problème on trouvera d'autres
sources d'approvisonnement entre nous un
mois le premier truc que j'ai fait en
arrivant medef c'était de créer un
comité souveraineté là aussi ça avait un
peu étonné et certains la souveraineté
ou l'autonomie stratégique si on préfère
de l'europe c'est devenu maintenant une
question centrale parce que quand on a
40% l'aluminium qui vient de russie bat
ça pose un problème donc les entreprises
les plus affectées par cette guerre se
serait lesquels
l'automobile certainement
l'aéronautique à cause à cause du titane
mais après c'est tout le monde parce que
quand le prix de l'énergie montrent tous
les industriels l'énergie intensif c'est
à dire l'aluminium l'acier etc sont
impactées et puis plein globalement
globalement du pêcheur aux transporteurs
routiers en passant par le chauffeur de
taxi avec un gazole au dessus de 2 euros
c'est forcément compliqué alors
justement il ya eu un plan de résilience
qui a été annoncé par le premier
ministre qui prévoit une prise en charge
de la moitié du surplus des dépenses de
gaz en fonction de certains critères le
chiffre d'affaires au moins 300 ou les
pertes d'exploitation est ce que ça vous
paraît bien calibré ce que ça vous
paraît suffisant nous on avait été très
clair dès le départ avant enfin que ce
plan des sciences quand j'étais à
matignon il faut pas revenir ou quoi
qu'il en coûte d'abord parce que et ça
c'est pas ça qui l'entourent encore
annoncer des mesures ciblées alors on
peut vous trouverez toujours des gens y
compris sur le medef pas d'hier n'a pas
assez et d'autres pour qu'il y en ait
trop c'est le le le couac en le
quotidien d'où il vient d'une décision
par complètement compris ce qu'était on
arrête l'économie complètement là on
n'est pas dans ce cas là on est sur des
tensions d'approvisionnement çà et là
dans l'est pour autant ça vous paraît
suffisant cette présence ce stade de ce
que je peux lire sur la répercussion de
la guerre en ukraine oui dans trois mois
je vous répondrai peut-être différemment
si on voit les événements et l'économie
évolué
mais parce que on peut pas d'abord on
peut pas se payer un quoi qu'il en coûte
permanent
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que le crois que d'un coup
tu sais pas ce qu'on a fait moins 10 de
pub au moins huit ou moins neuf vous
crier quand même passé avec l'arrière en
ukraine côté on n'en est pas là encore
une fois un jeu on n'en est pas là et
puis j'ai offert une dernière réponse
comme philosophique justement on n'est
pas entrepreneur pour chaque fois qu'on
est une difficulté tant de la main je
dis ça d'ailleurs mes collègues patrons
d'entreprises écouter avec pas de
discours sur les baisses de charges
c'est pas la même chose pendant ces deux
discours différents il y en a un qui est
mettez nous les mêmes conditions que les
autres
que les allemands
lajus que ce à quoi je fais allusion
c'est de dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya
une difficulté externe faut que cette
aventure l on se tourne vers l'état
alors il ya des cas partie comprend le
pêcheur il peut plus travailler mais
s'ils voulaient fondamentalement le
risque l'incertitude fait quand même
partie de l'entreprise et du rôle
d'entrepreneur sinon faut changer de
métier fois les faut faire fonctionner
ce plan de résidence jean castex a quand
même annoncé d'autres mesures notamment
un relèvement des prêts garantis par
l'état à 35% du chiffre d'affaires au
lieu de 25% aujourd'hui il annonce aussi
un nouveau prêt garanti par l'état au
mois de juillet ce que ça ce sont de
bonnes mesures oui c'est très très très
ciblée
et
relèvement ou le nouveau qui reviennent
un petit pot même c'est vraiment quand
on est impacté par
la guerre en russie c'est à dire qu'on a
un fort taux d'intrants je m'appelle et
de métal par exemple qui vient de russie
où un fort taux de l'énergie donc il va
par ailleurs une ruée sur et
heureusement d'ailleurs sur ccp jeu
déplafonné vous en avez parlé un petit
peu tout à l'heure mais le gouvernement
veut pouvoir se passer du gaz du pétrole
russe d'ici 2027 tout à l'heure vous
avez dit les allemands 10 en trois ans
c'est faisable donc 2027 pour vous a
nommé au box office a plus vite beaucoup
plus vite pour moi c'est une affaire
d'un an d'accord bien pourquoi c'est 3 %
les achats de fonds pèse 3 pins et de
meilleur réalisé on pèse 3 % des ventes
de gaz russe en europe et ça pèse 17 %
nous apprend une langue as d'autres
prénoms et qui ne font pas tout tout
évidemment toute l'énergie donc généré
exemple simple je crois qu'il ya une
dizaine d'installations de biogaz donc
le biogaz cédule la méthanisation de
déchets à l'école qui attendent une
autorisation
j'ai vu que le président de l'apic dans
son programme de candidat proposé une
loi d'exception jeu pas comme il
appelait ça pour accélérer je crois
qu'il faut pourrait combler les
associations non mais ça peut faire
partie 2 de même que pour accélérer et
alors là c'est un sujet compliqué mais
il faut aussi je pense une loi
d'habilitation pour les parcs éoliens
mois ils sont comme antenne rend chez
moi j'ai le premier parc éolien qui va
écouter je vais vous répondre non mais
je suis citoyen et voilà ça fait partie
de ma maman il faut aussi accepter que
si on veut se passer du gaz russe si on
veut
contribuer au nom réchauffement de la
planète fin ou du moins limiter le
réchauffement il faut des éoliennes il
faut lille il faut bien quelque part
vous avez
pour 60% et lien mais enfin là partout
hein donc pendant juste pour là dessus
on peut accélérer cette transition il
faut des investissements il faut des
lois d'habitation qui
raccourcissent tous les recours divers
et variés et diamants il faut une
décision la quatrième à gregor la
patronne des tgv mais on a d'autres
délinquants dit besson
nos températures j'ai pas combien
échauffés studio de lcp qui fait assez
chaud
parce que vous êtes presque deux mois
dans la sobriété quoi vous nous demandez
vraiment plus et pas soit ce qu'était
croissance et sobriété énergétique c'est
pas tout à fait la bd croissance mais
c'est pas le visage et un discours sur
le renouvelable sur la sobriété
énergétique mais parce qu'on n'a pas
choisi la canche quoi on veut pas
dépendre de gaz russe 20 voiliers qui
alors évidemment on aime dire s'il ya
une révolution en wifi bon ça change
tout mais vrai on n'en est pas là mais
il y aussi une aide de 35 centimes
d'euros par litre pour les pêcheurs un
fonds de 400 millions d'euros pour les
agriculteurs et le btp pour vous
personne n'a été oublié dans ce plan ont
déjà les chauffeurs de taxi ondes et en
france donc je suis sûr et certain que
vous aurez toujours
personne ne s'est manifesté auprès de
vous pour vous dire du medef
si un petit sujet sur l'aluminium qui
utilisent énormément d'énergie la
fameuse usine d'aluminium dunkerque en
train de regarder globalement le plan et
équilibrée il répond aux problèmes
actuels alors il ya aussi dans le plan
de résidence des chèques relance export
et d'échecs veilleux pour les
entreprises exportatrices est ce que
vous craignez un impact sur notre
déficit commercial
certaine manière il peut être positif si
on arrête de commercer avec la russie
alors je crois que la balance avec la
russie était quasiment à zéro donc
directement l déficit commercial il est
depuis trente ans
habib sy mal et il bougera pas beaucoup
dans un sens ou dans l'autre l'énergie
il fait varier un tout petit peu le prix
de l'énergie va le faire monter pour
répondre à ce défi de commercial c'est
un effort de compétitivité énorme et
dans la durée parce qu'il est de 84,7
milliards alors que l'allemagne a un
excédent de 173 milliards
les mesures qu'il faudrait prendre pour
vous c'est quoi ces baisser encore les
impôts de production pour redonner sa
complice et c'est alors là si vous me
laissez une
rgc mac ou pc cette question là parce
que ça me
on est frappé par le oui merci mais ce
que je vais battre phrase on deviendrait
du terme entre sur certains produits
pardon non mais détruit non mais pardon
joue l'économie c'est pas une mesure
c'est justement par une série de mesures
la série de mesures ça va de l'anglais à
l'école pour qu'on apprenne à exporter
à des problèmes de compétitivité sur
certain c'est qu'à la kinky ce qu'on
était avantageuse une belle déchets et
il n'y a pas que la fiscalité parce
qu'on a aussi un problème de
positionnement sur certains produits
parce qu'on est trop bas de gamme parce
qu'on sait pas exporter en meute parce
qu'on travaille pas bien à
l'international donc malheureusement on
a mis 30 ans a pas de licorne aussi ou
très peu et licorne joue pas beaucoup
donc commerce extérieur dont on a mis
trente ans à détruire la par détruire
disons avoir un appareil de production
qui est pas compétitifs malheureusement
j'ai presque envie de dire on va mettre
30 ans à retrouver peut-être pas 30 mai
10 ou 15 à retrouver les perspectives
oui on va parler d'un problème
un autre problème aujourd'hui et
maintenant l'augmentation du prix du
carburant plusieurs opérations de
blocages des barrages filtrants
aujourd'hui en tout lieu pour protester
contre le prix du carburant pour
réclamer des aides supplémentaires ce
que vous comprenez ce mouvement de
contestation des routiers des chauffeurs
de taxi etc encore une fois il y aura
toujours des gens pour trouver le prix
va baisser puisque comme vous savez le
prix du baril est redescendu donc il ya
toujours 3 à 4 semaines de délai entre
la hausse et la baisse donc ça va
rebaisser
après une très haut aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr mais les chauffeurs de taxi je pense
que malheureusement il faut qu'il passe
c'est le propre de l'inflation il faut
qu'ils passent à leur client final
puisque c'est réguler je crois les choix
tactiques contrairement régulière enfin
combien moreau vtc je devrais pas cité
de mari il faut qu'il passe une partie
de cette hausse à leur client final mais
déjà les consommateurs qui doit payer ça
mais un moment par exemple mais
mais mais pardon enfin je lui dis je à
maman contient vous y ranger glissement
de matière dans toute économie normale
la hausse de matière la hausse de
matières premières restent pas tu as
fait une matière première elle se
répercute dans la chaîne de valeur le
prix du blé qui a triplé à maman prix de
la baguette va augmenter c'est foot - de
l'économie vous proposer que du coup que
les taxis arrive avec un peu plus au
compteur pour lorsqu'ils prennent un
client spécialiste des taxis donc je
connais pas toutes les problèmes et le
rap on peut effectivement me semble en
tout cas une partie de cette hausse doit
être répercutée aux clients comme une
partie de la hausse je sais pas quoi moi
des poutrelles en acier va être
répercutée dans le coût du bâtiment etc
etc c'est à ces deux c'est une leçon
d'économie j'ai à dire de base en classe
est aussi un problème cette hausse du
prix des carburants pour de nombreux
salariés quels efforts les entreprises
sont elles prêtes à faire nous on a
proposé des les salariés assez simple
c'est que c'est qu'il existe des chèques
carburants qui sont utilisés pour des
concours de vendeurs et hermes est très
limité on devrait pouvoir utiliser en
tout cas de manière ponctuelle ces
chèques car banques sont défiscalisées
pour l'entreprise et pour le salarié à
la main de l'entreprise pour par exemple
ce qu'il ne faut pas la distribuer à
tout le monde dira fois c'est les gens
qui non mais tous les gens qui habitent
à plus de
24km tous les jours c'est très vrai en
fait dans les territoires ce que le
prononce très différents dans ce projet
il faut pas une mesure générale il faut
une mesure à la main donc on l'a proposé
au gouvernement et c'est à l'étude c'est
à l'étude donc c'est intéressant de
surveiller ce que
80 % des salariés français viennent en
voiture on peut peut-être faire mieux ou
moins - si vous voulez mais on va papa
c'est un papa ça devienne sincérité % ça
ça n'existe pas un autre sujet de
préoccupation majeur qui est la dette
locaux vides elle a alourdi
considérablement on est un près de 3000
milliards de dette 120% du pib ça vous
inquiète oui alors ça m'inquiète oui
mais d'une certaine manière le chiffre
en valeur absolue a son importance bien
sûr donc c'est le japon est à 200% du
pib et a côtoyé beaucoup moins et
l'allemagne à 60 je veux dire par là
c'est que au fond comme tout endettement
c'est la capacité en bourse et catalans
bourse et c'est quoi c'est la capacité à
faire de la croissance donc avoir des
recettes fiscales qui rentre petit 1 et
avoir des budgets en équilibre et donc
notre préoccupation elle est aussi ou
surtout de commencer à être en capacité
de montrer à nos prêteurs puisqu'on est
endettée auprès du monde entier que on
est en capacité à mons et donc c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs pour boucler avec la
question que vous me posiez tout à
l'heure que on n'a pas demandé pour les
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine 1
quoi qu'il en coûte supplémentaire parce
que là on gère je pense qu'on décrit
bizet complètement la parole de la
france est-ce que les 3% ces fameux
critères de maastricht 60% points à des
3% pour le déficit budgétaire public
pardon est ce que vous pensez pas que ça
nous a fait faire des erreurs est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas investi davantage
dans l'hôpital dans le salaire de nos
soignants dans le salaire des des
professeurs par exemple est-ce que je ne
crois pas que ce soit les 3 % parce que
les trempe on les a crevés vous savez
c'était 3 et 60 passant de de dettes de
dette donc les deux on les a par don de
parler trivialement série objectif d'y
revenir non mais avec l'objectif de
dépenser de l'argent
le problème c'est là que notre capacité
en france c'est pas qu'en france a
dépensé dans des dépenses de
fonctionnement pas toujours utiles et
pas dans des banques d'investissement la
qualité de la dépense publique moi moi
je suis pas
c'est leur maîtrise des dépenses moi je
suis pas un présent mais ce qui dit faux
pas de dépenses publiques bien sûr qu'il
faut de la dépense une foule bien des
dépenses dans l'éducation
c'est pendant l'éducation on est plutôt
parmi les pays qui dépensent le plus
dans l'éducation
classement et quand vous regardez tous
les classements internationaux et les
plus mauvais donc que nos jeunes profs
sont très mal payés par rapport aux
années donc c'est vrai que l'argent est
mal dépensé moi je suis assez favorable
a augmenté le salaire des professeurs
mais à ce moment là faut faire des
économies ailleurs donc c'est plutôt de
la qualité de dépense publique qui est
temps que donc c'est 3% là c'est un
chien que vous voulez conserver non pas
forcément je pense que la discussion qui
avait commencé avant la guerre en
ukraine sur c'est quoi les nouveaux
critères intelligente elle et elle est
saine il faut avoir des règles parce que
sinon j'ai à dire c'est open bar et on
sait que là la nature du politique fait
que quand même quand c'est open bar la
dépense publique fils faut trouver
décrites et intérieure et qui
corresponde à la situation réelle
demande et 60% de dette sur pie balcon
et à 120 et ses boutures les garder mais
ça n'a aucun sens alors pour retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre
certains disent qu'il faut augmenter
l'âge de départ à la retraite certains
plaident même pour 65 ans est ce que
vous vous y être favorable mais pas vous
surprendre ça fait partie du programme
de medef depuis quelques années nous ont
dit simplement deux choses la première
c'est que on a l'espérance de vie qui
augmente et donc ce qui con est passé de
65 à 60 ans 80 l'âge moyen
d'espérance de vie à la retraite je
parle de dé c'était 14 ans maintenant je
crois que ces 22 ou 23 je suis plus
qu'un chiffre exactement donc il ya une
petite partie qui doit être consacrée au
travail mais en prenant en compte l'âge
de rentrer dans le marché du travail et
la pénibilité donc on doit pouvoir
trouver un chemin et c'est la réforme
urgente parce que celle qui nous donnent
des manoeuvres financières pour investir
ailleurs pour investir dans l'école pour
investir dans la santé donc oui c'est
oui mais on n'a pas le choix et le faire
sans complexifié et rendre anxiogène la
réforme du système à points ça nous
votre alors il reste 5 minutes le smic
devrait augmenter avant l'été de 25
euros net par mois c'est une
augmentation automatique
est-ce que c'est supportable pour les
entreprises
c'est la loi donc le smic va augmenter
et voulait pas le choix quand le smic
augmente en fait ça évidemment un effet
sur tous les autres salaires assez
logiquement donc on rentre un tout petit
peu dans la boucle inflation la spirale
inflationniste moult régime ça fait
partie bizarrement quand les salaires
augmentent notamment dans des métiers
jeu pour la restauration par exemple le
salaire c'est 60% à peu près du à face à
dépendre évidemment de du niveau du
restaurant mais en moyenne forcément ça
va se retrouver sur la carte
donc oui ça répond un peu la question de
tout à l'heure sur l'inflation ça va il
contribuait va obliger à revaloriser
certaines grilles est ce que le niveau
de rémunération des bas salaires en
france il n'est pas trop bas oui il est
trop bas et il est trop bas en
particulier personne ne le dit mais
quand vous êtes dans des métropoles le
coût de la vie et pas du tout le même
quand vous habitez dans une ville de 20
mille habitants que le loyer c'est le
premier poste du pouvoir d'achat on y
passe et c'est le logement et le
logement pardon je m'arrête là dessus
deux minutes grand absent de la campagne
il va nous manquer cette année pendant
2021 il nous a manqué à peu près 120
mille logements qu'on n'a pas construit
et les permis de construire continuent à
diminuer notamment sur le collectif
paradoxe est qu en plus à l'inter des
permis de construire il ya plus de
maisons individuelles - objectif ça veut
dire quoi si vous restreignez l'offre de
logement les prix montent les prix à la
propriété donc c'est à dire que les
jeunes plus devenir propriétaires et les
prix à la location
en partie dans les zones tendues donc
les métropoles et donc ça veut dire que
cette partie là qui représente un poste
très important et moins on est payé plus
le poids du logement coûte cher et donc
la meilleure façon de répondre à ce
problème la question pourrait augmenter
les salaires maurice et des emprises qui
sont généralement dans des marges très
faibles c'est deux choses l'état donne
l'exemple dans tous les appels d'offres
publics parce que c'est que les appels
de piles pour le nettoyage pour le
gardiennage pour la sécurité c'est
toujours au mieux disant avec des prix
tirés au plus bas et 2 contres des blocs
l'offre de logement pour permettre aux
employés de baisser à l'axel approprié
de baisser et que ça soit en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat des catégories les moins
favorisées une augmentation des bas
salaires comme le propose comme beaucoup
de candidats ça veut dire quoi une
augmentation des bas c'est à moi j'ai
pas un bouton pour dire augmenter les
bas salaires parce que quand une fois
vous êtes restaurateur vous êtes je
prendre un autre exemple vous êtes dans
la propreté propreté 85 % de la facture
c'est le salaire vous dites quoi au
ministère de la défense où le ministère
de l'éducation nationale vous dites je
vous augmenter mon mon prix oui c'est
comme ça que ça marche donc on peut pas
décréter l'augmentation des salaires et
c'est pas des entreprises qui font des
marges faramineuses je disais tout à
l'heure que ça dépend effectivement du
logement les dépenses contraintes est ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer un smic à
géométrie variable ça existait jusque
dans les années 70 sa région et
d'ailleurs les salaires sont moins
élevés dans les pme et en province je
pense que c'est pas audible
politiquement mais ça correspond à une
réalité de pouvoir d'achat pas de
voiliers de de dépenses contraintes à
cause du logement essentiellement alors
il ya une autre proposition qu'on
n'entend pas mal dans la campagne qui
est faut-il conditionner le rsa à une
activité une formation ou des travaux
d'intérêt général qu'est ce que vous en
pensez - philosophiquement j'y suis
favorable c'est vrai que
un
assistanat pour reprendre l'expression
enfin une allocation qui n'a pas de
contrepartie peut paraître j'allais dire
pas incitative alors la difficulté ça
aujourd'hui oui le mot assisté en dit
c'est une assistance une allocation
quelque soit le nom qu'on lui donne dans
lequel en face duquel n'y a pas de
contrepartie quand vous avez l'assurance
chômage c'est parce que vous avez
travaillé quand vous avez les
allocations vieillesse vous avez des
enfants là il n'y a pas de contrepartie
ben on peut imaginer qu'on prédit et la
difficulté c'est de trouver je crois
qu'il ya 500 g plus le chiffre exact
cinq cent mille personnes qui sont
suffisamment de formation c'est ça pour
ces gens suffisamment de déboucher le
principe me paraît
philosophiquement en tout cas en tant de
table la difficulté c'est de trouver des
entreprises des formations ou des
associations pour les accueillir
j'irai pas les choses comme ça parce que
il ya des gens qui sembleraient ça
tomberait à la est d'ailleurs déjà à la
rue etc c'est plus le le fallait pas
comment il et je n'ai pas écouté la
citation christophe castagnet mais le
fait de dire à quelqu'un des pardons de
lire comme ça c'est aussi une forme de
dignité donner de l'argent à quelqu'un
comme ça j'ai à dire enfin entre
guillemets gratuitement ou au contraire
lui dire mais tu as un rôle à jouer dans
la société dans une association où tu
vas te former ou tu vas très surprise
euros en fait ça correspond à peu près à
mi temps à 6 euros c'est de la main
d'oeuvre pas chère aussi pour les
entreprises c'est la nettement ses
excuses moi de dire ça comme ça mais
c'est plutôt un problème pour les
entreprises accueillir quelqu'un qui n'a
pas de formation pendant 12 heures dans
une entreprise il faut quelqu'un pour le
surveiller en plus être tout les le
risque d'accident du travail et serveurs
et pense qu'il fait
on va on le voit bien d'ailleurs parce
qu'il ya eu tout un plan un jeune une
solution sur lequel on s'est beaucoup
mobilisée pour accueillir des jeunes pas
en apprentissage que ça ça a bien marché
mais qu'ils sont résolus et de l'emploi
qui ont pas été en en tout cas qu'en
font quitter sud depuis deux ans
l'esprit ce qu'ils ont fait c'est un
coup en réalité parce qu'effectivement
le jeu n'est pas rémunéré par mais il
faut du temps de de monitorat de
manteaux ring de surveillance merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
on devrait vous poser une question sur
le but je vais faire maintenant voile et
les courbes de kobe de remonter et avec
la désorganisation dans les entreprises
bref est ce que ça vous inquiète
je sais pas moi je suis pas pareil je
suis pas scientifique donc je vois qu'il
ya nouveaux variants b1 il s'appelle ba2
où je pas quoiqu'il en chine moi ce que
j'espère c'est qu'on arrive j'allais
dire presque domestique locaux vides
comme on a domestiqué la grippe annuelle
et c'est effectivement il va pas
disparaître mais on puisse mais là est
ce qu'on vous sûrs ce qu'on voulait des
remontées qui vous font dire que les
entreprises sont à nouveau aujourd'hui
n'est organisée aujourd'hui on est bien
dans six mois je demandais monsieur
fontanet ou monsieur delfraissy yves
thréard nous a rejoint directeur adjoint
du figaro yves c'est à vous qu'on soit
les abeilles bonsoir joffard rebondir
alors on va parler un peu politique
et parce qu'on fait depuis tout à
l'heure si bien et tout est politique
c'est ce que vous avez dit d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure mais
sur la campagne électorale quand même
parce qu'il ya un moment la france via
un moment important il ya eu la crise
sanitaire maintenant j'ai vu une
campagne électorale jusqu'à la chapelle
saint sava questions reliées à un truc
imaginez ma question il ya eu la crise
d'un sanitaire puis immédiatement la
guerre en ukraine sans que la crise
sanitaire soit complètement fini
d'ailleurs et beaucoup disent la craie
la campagne a été escamoté c'est votre
avis je prenais pas le mot escamoter les
événements ont fait que personne n'est
responsable vous avez fait votre travail
les hommes politiques ont fait leur
travail sauf que ce qui domine
l'actualité et c'est normal c'est 7 t/an
d'ukraine ça a été le co vide c'est
comme ça c'est dommage pour le plan
démocratique mais je vois pas très bien
ce qu'on peu ce qu'on peut y faire on
peut essayer de parler dans votre
émission dans d'autres mais on voit bien
que c'est pas ça qui préoccupent les
français et on peut le comprendre alors
certains observateurs sont inquiets
quand même parce qu'il se dise le débat
finalement on n'a pas eu lieu projet
contre projet sur des sujets très
importants les retraites le temps de
travail
les sujets d'assez que sur relatifs à la
sécurité à l'immigration tout ça tout ça
n'a pas eu lieu il n'y a pas une
confrontation projet contre projet et
donc beaucoup se disent oh la la
il pourrait y avoir un troisième tour
social ou une colère populaire dans les
rues comme on a vécu avec et gilet jaune
que personne n'avait vu venir d'ailleurs
c'est ce que je sais ce que j'ai voulu
répondre c'est les mouvements sociaux
surtout en france ils sont totalement
imprévisibles souvenez l'édito de du
monde là dessous et ensuite la france
sans doute aujourd'hui donc voulait
gilet jaune aurait peut-être vous met
vraiment en tout cas ont voulu venir et
c'était avec un gazole à je sais plus
combien 45 ans papa tu es
donc je ne sais pas vous répondre moi je
suis pas de ceux qui disent il ya un
problème de l'estimé pour celui qui sera
élu et c'est non on s'est quand même à
quoi s'attendre grosso modo avec les
principaux candidats
voyez les grandes mesures ce qui est sûr
par contre c'est que ce qui n'est pas
annoncée avant on parlait de la retraite
tout à l'heure je pense ou moi je sais
bien que tous les candidats je crois que
maintenant ils sont tous positionnés
pour la dans l'âme en avant le contre
une allure et
jean-luc ont la chance de revenir
sentant les choses sont claires la
réforme alors à la légitimité pas quelle
que soit d'ailleurs ce qu'il apporte y
compris si jean luc mélenchon la
légitimité du suffrage universel c'est
plus au fond ce quinquennat il rend le
temps d'action assez court le canada qui
vient de s'écouler
si
ça vous laisse un nom pour agir mais au
fond c'est pas si mal parce que vous
êtes un nostalgique du septennat
oui ou non mais en tout cas on est
spécialiste de multiplier législation et
ont fait loi sur loi sans jamais se
préoccuper de savoir si la loi dans tous
les décrets ont été publiés
et si elle a marché ou pas sans retour
d'expérience là je pense qu'on aura un
nom quel que soit le président pour un
gir et quatre ans pour refaire le
service après-vente et voir ce qui a
marché pas marché c'est ken pourquoi ce
serait différent mais c'est un peu tôt
mais c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé que
le président actuel
il a eu un nom pour agir en qualité
en faire davantage oui les événements
ont fait que mais je pense que la
légitimité démocratique l'accélération
du temps démocratique fait aussi que et
se trouve assez simple c'est les anglais
ont un système formidable qui et quand
vous voter une loi au bout de cinq ans
si elle n'est pas repassé au parlement
pour un sav un service après-vente elle
tombe attendrait moi je suis assez
favorable à cela ou seriez pas favorable
à ça je suis favorable à un réexamen
régulier de ce qui a été fait c'est ce
qu'ont fait j'ai à dire non vraiment la
dose d'action
dans les entreprises si vous voulez et
je prends un exemple un peu
opérationnels la loi formation de 2018
qui a créé le cpf compte personnel de
formation et qui a aussi booster
l'apprentissage elle a des avantages
formidable bond les peu le medef à
l'époque étaient bons tout contre mais
vous dire que les chiffres
d'apprentissage sont exceptionnels mais
on voit bien que le cpf vous avez dû
recevoir des sms madame martichoux vous
avez 3202 euros sur votre compte
dépêchez vous de vous faire former
machin on voit bien que le truc qui est
quand même on a donc il faut revenir en
arrière faisons un bilan rationnelle des
passionnés de cette loi donc 2018 et
cinq ans après 2023 et on décide tous
ensemble qu'il faut faire ça c'est de la
bonne gouvernance et la mauvaise
gouvernance et ont fait la loi à gec sur
le recyclage bien ans après la loi de
climat résidences sont les mêmes sujets
d'accords et ils étaient près de la
belgique sont pas parus il ya une
j'ai parlé de l'absence de débat il ya
une chose aussi qui inquiète beaucoup
c'est l'abstentionnisme et et les deux
cumulent effet que via un président du
sénat qui sort un jour une phrase qui
est quand même assez lourde en dix ans
le président élu en parlant d'ailleurs
du président sortant pourrait n'être pas
légitime c'est votre regard non je me
préoccupe de la soie de l'abstention
comme comme vous tous je m'en préoccupe
d'autant plus que la démocratie recule
dans le monde et le medef a un rôle à
jouer justement pour inciter les gens à
voter je suis pas sûr que si le medef
disais allez voter pardon de dire ça
avec la souris serait mal vu même avec
un président le sympathique comme moi ça
serait bien vu donc non
évidemment ce n'est pas aux chefs
d'entreprise allez dire aux jeunes
d'aller voter non là on a un rôle si
vous voulez yves c'est vrai que la
campagne est assez frustrante c'est que
le vrai débat qui devrait nous occuper
c'est celui de la transition écologique
qu'est l'enjeu majeur pour notre pour
notre mode de vie comment on finance
comment on investit parce que produire
vers ça coûte plus cher et ça il a pas
eu lieu et il a pas eu lieu parce qu'il
est un peu masqué si vous avez vous avez
site vous avez eu un mot tout à l'heure
très important qui résument d'ailleurs
l'état d'esprit général à la fois après
cette crise sanitaire et pendant cette
guerre la souveraineté il faut recouvrir
une souveraineté industriels
pharmaceutiques
agricoles
hélas a pas eu lieu ça ce débat car
dernièrement c'est devenu un consensus
nous on a fait un grand oral des
candidats souffre le président qui
n'étaient pas déclarées de fabien
roussel un marine le pen tout le monde
parle de réindustrialisation évidemment
mais pas exactement les mêmes avec les
mêmes moyens non plus nous alors je peux
le dire d'autant plus que ça je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure quand j'ai mis ce mot
souveraineté ou et qui a des
connotations à ces politiques en fait un
au medef beckett admis maintenant oui et
je parle s'assurer qu'à l'époque ait eu
des soucis qui se sont qu'ils se sont
levés avec étonnement il faut pas tomber
dans le protectionnisme
il faut que c'est quoi au finalement
l'autonomie stratégie de la souveraineté
c'est que collectivement et proment au
niveau européen autant qu'au niveau
français on décide ce dont on a besoin
ce dont il faut produire nos deux pays
et ce qu'on peut acheter et si on est
suffisamment diversifié où l'acheter en
fait je veux dire d'une autre manière on
a poussé le principe de ricardo à
l'extrême principe de ricardo c'est un
économiste du cmc on va produire les
biens les services à l'endroit le plus
perfectionné donc tous les semi
conducteurs à taïwan voilà tous les
masques en chine tout le gaz en russie
etc etc et on s'aperçoit finalement que
l'histoire s'est pas l'histoire est
tragique et donc oui les nations sont
réveillés et la russie éternelle s'est
réveillée c'est pas des amis de l'europe
donc l'europe ne va pas de l'atlantique
à l'oural
s'arrête sur le dniepr alors je vais
vous poser une question qui va peut-être
vous surprendre
l'armée c'est une entreprise et je parle
un réserviste
l'armée c'est pas une entreprise
non
j'étais
en question bon on arrive grosso modo je
crois 2% du du produit intérieur brut en
termes de budgets militaires certains
veulent le pousser beaucoup plus il est
probable d'ailleurs que le président
sera obligé de pousser le budget plus de
le faire croire comme en allemagne
d'ailleurs est ce que c'est une bonne
chose oui enfin je sais pas si c'est une
bonne chose c'est bien on rêverait tous
d'un monde désormais enfin la réalité
c'est vous m'avez déjà dit oui n'était
pas une entreprise à l'ordre c'est pas
une emprise pourquoi parce que si vous
voulez le jas dire le chiffre d'affaires
ou le bénéfice il est généralement
intangible c'est une protection et
l'échec c'est la mort ou en tout cas la
blessure dont on n'est pas dans le même
même si peur des parallèles et je vous
dis ça ancien des forces spéciales
passées comme et un univers je connais
assez bien donc oui on va être obligé de
monter le budget de la défense
parce qu'on avait une armée qui était
configuré pour les guerres des forces
spéciales d'ailleurs pour les guerres en
afrique pour des interventions
ponctuelles contredit la liste et que là
c'est le retour de la guerre dit à haute
intensité en europe le général burkhardt
qui est le chef d'état major actuel
avait il ya un an et demi un avait fait
une déclaration disant c'est le retour
des guerres à haute intensité tout le
monde avait regardé ça un peu on dire
bon c'est un militaire du pognon c'est
classique non avec d'ailleurs une chose
quand même intéressante je trouve c'est
que ce qui se passe en ukraine là je
vous donne un commentaire plus personnel
que président du medef on voit que c'est
une guerre à haute intensité mais ou
avec des missiles stinger ou déjà vli
nasser add on arrive donc avec des
moyens relativement peu sophistiquée on
arrive à des résultats qui fait c'est
l'armée russe ne progresse pas et elle a
un autre sens et marc médine hyper
puissante qui manque d'essence et qui a
des problèmes de logistique donc ça
montre que la dgde le chiffre absolu de
passages du film n'est pas la seul
critère à mettre en oeuvre bref aux
normes européennes je crois que c'est
une illusion je crois que c'est une
illusion l'armée européenne c'est une
somme de militaires de plusieurs pays
sous un commandement
d'un petit extra
quand vous avez je veux dire d'une autre
manière moi je connais bien la pologne
quand vous avez les russes à 1000
kilomètres tout plat avec des bouleaux
et des chars qui peuvent débouler vous
raisonnez pas pareil que quand vous êtes
au portugal et que avant que ça arrive
non mais je dis ça avec j'ai évidemment
rien comporte une guerre contre les
polonais mais l'idée de d'armée
européenne à 27 je pense est une
illusion l'idée d'avoir des accords de
défense privilégié avec quelques pays ce
qui est positif et je pense la bonne
solution
la faune qui s'appelle la tendance
suivra vous aller à contre-courant
d'ailleurs de ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre lui-même dans son premier
discours de politique générale géré
elizabeth quand il y a dit le problème
en france c'est que l'intendance ne suit
pas
on était à mi parcours du dieu de la
crise ça ne respire et l'inde en suivant
c'est une phrase de de gaulle bien sûr
est-ce que on a fait des progrès dans ce
domaine juste
le coc vide nous a fait tous progressé à
tout ça parce que j'ai a dit on était
dans un tas de il nous a quand même
failli conscience de nos insuffisances
collective et quand je dis ça je mets
les entreprises
est ce qu'il en restera quelque chose
je pense collectivement moi j'ai quand
même été très frappé je redonne cet
exemple du grand oral du medef où tout
le monde et il nous faut une industrie
forte parce qu'on peut pas abandonner
complètement sact ans acteurs de
l'économie donc il restera quelque chose
donc oui on a fait des progrès est-ce
qu'on est au bon niveau pour les 30 ans
qui viennent je pas encore c'est encore
beaucoup trop de bureaucratie alors ça
c'est la partie
j'ai à dire je sais pas comment le dire
oui m'enfin bureaucratie c'est un peu un
terme g et oui on a une capacité j'ai
pas comment dire à faire un filtre de
toutes les décisions qui d'ailleurs
président a parlé plusieurs fois qui
reste assez fort on n'est pas un pays
qui est capable sauf dans des
circonstances sexuel de se mobiliser
rapidement
vous disais tout à l'heure
effectivement que la guerre d'une
certaine façon
bouleverse parfois les réalités en tout
cas tel qu'on les perçoit
les prix les équipements militaires et
bien vous le disiez vous avez parlé dans
gala merkel c'est quand même fascinant
de voir que sa stratégie énergétique est
aujourd'hui
remise en question et comme
contre-productive face à l'événement ça
vous inspire
je vais pas accabler un gars merkel qui
a fait beaucoup de choses l'allemagne
était dans une santé économique
extraordinaire mais je pense qu'elle a
été
comme d'autres naïf vis-à-vis de poutine
dont on pensait que bon c'était pas une
démocratie
voulait faire un peu d'expansion mais il
avait un comportement rationnel qu'on
pouvait qu on pouvait comprendre mais je
vous dire j'étais en ukraine mois de
juillet j'ai rencontré plaisance et les
skis j'ai rencontré le maire de kiev ils
m'ont parlé de rentrer dans le temps de
la menace des russes je veux la vérité
va dîner le soir ex ambassadeur bon
c'est pas pris ça complètement sérieux
donc je vais pas vous voyez je pense
qu'il faut être modeste les landes
l'histoire sont souvent nous prennent à
revers l'important c'est d'en tirer des
vingt dix pour cent des français ont
peur face à cette guerre
non non je pense qu'il faut être lucide
sur ce qui a en face on c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui a décidé
de manière unilatérale et sans d'une
rationalité qui pourrait être la nôtre
d'attaqué quelles qu'en soient les
conséquences seront bien d'ailleurs qui
ne cherchent pas gagné la guerre de
l'information donc non et la peur est la
plus mauvaise conseillère je dis ça au
passage je sais pas comment se
comporteraient mois nos concitoyens
si on se retrouvait en première ligne
les ukrainiens nous donne un exemple de
courage à ces extraordinaires dernière
question
j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous étiez
réservistes le président de la
république dans son programme insisté
sur ce point là c'est utile dans un pays
comme le nôtre garde et l'ukraine
regardez le crâne
ça peut paraître bizarre mais c'est des
réserves celle des kalachnikovs qui
empêche les rues d'avancé donc oui et
les entreprises ont un rôle à jouer pour
permettre aux réservistes de fait il
veut doubler les réserves croix dans les
saisons c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
qu'on peut essayer de porter et vous
avez raison toutes les familles ou
presque se pose la question de savoir ce
qu'elle ferait si
tuation que les ukrainiens merci
infiniment salon et est ce soir notre
invité geoffroy roux de bézieux on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à 19h30
pour audition publique sur la chaîne
parlementaire bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]